the famous fictional story of Robinson
Crusoe was actually based on real
maroonings most notably of a Scotsman
Privateer called Alexander Selkirk who
in 1703 was a sailing Master on a ship
that departed from Britain to go raid
Spanish shipping in the Pacific while
there were replenishing supplies on an
uninhabited Island Alexander voiced his
concerns about the sea worthiness of the
ship stating he would rather stay on
this uninhabited Island than Sail on
that broken ship the captain annoyed
with Alexander's remarks took him up on
the offer and despite Alexander's
protest that it was just a figure of
speech the captain left him on the
island the ship would eventually sing
while Alexander would go on to survive
on the island building a couple of hugs
hunting the local wild goats and
befriending the local feral cats after
four years and four months of solitude
another British privateering Expedition
anchored on the island to resupply only
to find Alexander who was incoherent
with joy to see them Alexander would
join them sailing across the Pacific
Indian and Atlantic Oceans back to
Britain circumnavigating the world while
doing a bunch of honest pirating along
the way